[Music]
in father neck news feather neck man in
feather Nick fed their neck what's that
a turkey we're about to find out but the
little neck that can get just really I
wondered if it was a phrase that I
didn't understand and so I'm sorry I
came to you ever heard a father neck
brother neck is it a sexual act so
that's what I was wondering if I was
just we're gonna find out if you read
the [ __ ] pie so maybe by our
breakfast all day I love breakfast all
day long I can't have it for dinner
though because I love coffee with
breakfast and a decaf that's true I
don't do you cap tastes okay you just
blue is mine if you tell me that it's
decaf it ruins it for me though no it
still [ __ ] me up
yeah I think yeah me too doctors found
several feathers caught in a toddler's
throat after one came out through her
neck what Oh God a pillow
she ate a chicken so she's a bird this
this kid is this kid is just [ __ ] with
like crafts corner and then he just like
took a handful and uhm yeah well for the
parents this was a little mystery uh so
the kid has this like well under her
neck like I mean like a hole as well you
know and and so like they see this
growth and it just starts getting bigger
it gets bigger like can you imagine if
this was on tyka the they see it and
then it it's swollen it gets in them by
the next day it's redder and then it
kind of comes to a head almost like it
looks almost like a pimple but they're
growing once something dude she's
growing feathers got stuck in her tonsil
it looks like when you like skin a
chicken they pulled this little pimples
yeah yeah
goosebumps like yeah like real big goose
but yeah
so it starts it's like this we have an
actual picture of what a load like I
can't I can't really zoom in on this
guy's but you can see looks like a
clitoris so they kind of took a picture
of it because it was getting more so
Lynette why is that look like a g-string
this is like surprisingly the day that
they were like all right what the [ __ ]
like they thought maybe this might go
down or something things like that on my
top it's getting worse and then I'm
sorry guys it was actually more like
right here just to be specific and so
eventually it comes to a head and the
mom pulls out a feather and they're like
it's like a magician trick and the
cameras come out it's Penn & Teller
believe it or not or something and then
she sets the feather free and it flies
oh my god well so they initially took
her trick so the doctor before they
pulled out the whole feather and they
thought a plant or something was growing
and they were like what the [ __ ] let's
test this but by the next day the
[ __ ] feather comes out how big is the
feather we're talking like a hawk
feather are you talking like a pillow
feathers bro when I first read this I
was thinking yeah like the one right
with the old pens that when I think
whether I'm going all out you know but I
mean it was a it was about it was like a
feather probably about it was it bloody
but they know well I don't know I I
don't have that detail don't have that
you say no yeah so they're completely
clean totally fresh feel like they're
just like peer stir like so what
happened was yes the child was eating
feathers from the couch get they so
stupid
we have feathers in our county I know
that is not done well he's not eating
weird [ __ ] thank God they actually
eventually solve it the like obviously
dude if my couch has a rip in it I'm
[ __ ] pissed you know so they actually
see that it's like leaking feathers but
they just so all is the kid suits are
just as toddler so you guys said how
would it go from here to here
no blood with no points caught it oh
there's definitely pus but we don't know
we don't know about blood for our own
sanity we're gonna say no but so what
actually happened blood under skin
here's what I think is even worse so the
child's wash sanity it's not there Nicky
and it got caught in the throat the
Brimley part just suck into the in the
kid never like cried I said like cuz you
know us we would be like yes something
like is something trying or not even
though there had to be other symptoms
involved well I mean the kid maybe was
crying God they could have just been
like I probably would have chalked it up
to this maybe this thing really hurts
okay you know what other games they have
so I'm sure the child is crying but of
course we don't really have details on
that but yeah so they so they they pull
the feather out they see exactly these
are the feathers in the couch the they
had gotten embedded in her throat and
basically the doctors concluded that
like a splinter it pushed the feathers
out of the box yeah no I'm sorry
the doctors extracted ten feathers just
every time like she swallowed it just
pushed it a little bit more like like
what's crazy me is that all of those
feathers got lodged like actually she
probably could have eaten 100 so what
she has a bunch of holes in her neck now
yeah they not check her poop poop up
dude I'm surprised a poop didn't come
out and [ __ ] [ __ ] a fly away it says the
poop actually flew away [ __ ] how did
she can heal the holes in her neck
there's not there's not really no every
time she swallows just to live the leaks
out evaders just the water they actually
went in and performed surgery on this
lung and they pulled out a clump of
about 20 feathers oh my god how'd she
not choke it up or something no what
cats do they eat random [ __ ] no their
first well there there there was video
but it won't load guys you don't to see
how about yeah I mean like but as a
parent if you had like an ailment like
that would you record the cake get the
camera we're gonna pull the [ __ ] I'd
be freaked the [ __ ] out I'm like you do
it let me know what happens bar would
pull the camera out while gos for you
know
I saw the giving birth video I had my
eyes closed the investment is still so
common though like I always share but
not maybe dad like of that nature I
think like one of my my little cousin
like got a dime stuck up his nose and
had to go get surgery
Isaac [ __ ] um would eat that couch
like it peels see this is totally normal
it's normal like any weird [ __ ] one time
I swallowed a bead when I was in like
kindergarten and I thought I was gonna
die I remember I had I didn't want to
tell anyone no it was an accident and I
don't want to tell anyone that I had
swallowed the bead but I went through
the whole day like this is it like I had
accepted that as a child I knew I knew
that it was over for me here I got to
show you guys one more picture oh it's
so it's actually not bloody here's one
of the feather pathology Mountain it's a
toddler baby Charlotte baby Charlotte
[ __ ] based on his face and that's like
three like two or three it's a girl baby
Charlotte there could be a male
Charlotte we know it's true I did I am
so sorry didn't mean to marginalize
middle names I apologize yeah I don't
know you know earlier I was thinking
like oh I want a kid now this just seems
complicated like I would be so
disappointed if my offspring I'm like oh
you're gonna be so smart you're gonna be
successful and they're just glue right
now he has a little scooter that he does
with one foot and he books it he goes
really fast but he doesn't want to stop
so he just throws himself on crash and
then he's like okay and then he drags it
and then he like goes full force and he
crashed into like a chairs
that's gonna be my blowing what some
figures ideas to break anything but stop
on my own what kids are just resilient
to pain and it takes a few years they're
all like rubbery for a reason they find
out later that they can gain sympathy
from the pain so now they have to tell
people I have a headache somebody used
to do I don't know it's like the old
people that get sick so the family comes
and visits them yeah yeah
that's too real that's real sad that's
one type of falls like we try not to
baby him you know
you said it's okay it's okay like we
just kind of make it positive and he
just kind of gets back up first if he's
like oh he's looking around it really
hurts them he wants you to kiss it as
soon as you kiss it literally it's gone
doesn't that but oh is it just by you or
barbar can do it too well I'm the first
in line then it's my mom and then it's
part but what's funny it has to be in
that order because like let's say Tiger
Falls right and I'm closer Tim deals all
day over there I go okay I'll kiss you
but have to be like I'm like third in
line it's grandma first then busy go up
and he goes Geo first and then after
that he goes up to Grandma yeah then
grandma has to do it yeah yeah yeah I
thought you have to like convince him
like Gio's not here she's not he knows
if Jill's not there he'll let me kiss it
let's say let's say Jill's not here and
it's just me and my dad and my dad tries
to kiss you but no you know what his
favorites are yeah I was around the most
maybe once deals first and then grandma
and then I don't know how from your
mom's there every day
the women are women are healers dudes
ain't got no healing yeah what do they
got yeah do you think I know healing in
oh yeah no yeah you go to you nurture
and stuff my husband he is very nervy
you'll be different he if you had a girl
maybe yeah Michael depart first mate
Rose might run to their dad because Leah
goes to Kristina and and it's so sad
he's like I took care of you those
vulgus in the beginning Pam or dad it's
the Adam dad and your mom what I was
holding her in a while that connection
of being grown inside of the mother
I was holding her in Hawaii and she like
it was right next to me she didn't give
a [ __ ] about it as soon as the mom came
she was like Oh mom and I was like damn
it
sorry bro it's like women just have this
like healing energy like yeah there's
something like this is off topic but on
topic there's some like study done where
mom's when they get injured they find
cells that are similar to the child on
your wounds wait wait oh [ __ ] what
so something we're like a mom like you
get a cut and then they analyze all the
cells around that wound and it look like
diapers and some of those cells are like
from a little face on it that's exactly
how cells work in your [ __ ] dude do you
guys know I've heard this before like
maybe I don't know but I've heard that
like when a mom is carrying a child if
the mom has really bad anxiety or she's
under a lot of stress because sometimes
your body stays really tense oh there's
kind of like vibrations and shaking you
can like pass that anxiety under the
child everything there's stuff like that
like epigenetics when when you're going
on while you're making the baby so right
now say Bart needs he'll of fat and then
they make the next child then that child
is more likely yeah bit more maybe
diabetes or who knows whereas if Bart
gets super Jack and Jill's looking yoked
when they have the next baby geoq funny
like but Gio's [ __ ] joke she's other
cover B I love the word yo getting it's
so funny yeah the state that your sex
cells and your partner's sex cells are
in after those are the yeah at that time
are them the genetic markers that are
passed on they think if you're like if
you're like really up on your whatever
little app to make a brain work better
you're doing therapy and you're doing
meditation you're doing all these things
at the time like you're your best self
at that moment you that might have a
better so I'm gonna wait till I'm a
billionaire and then have a kid and in
that kid's gonna be a bit I think it's
your physical don't think it has to do
with your back
I'm gonna wait till I grow my hair out
so the baby comes I have nice hair not
Joe millionaire mentality I'm with you
I'm waiting to man I'm waiting no but
maybe millionaire mentality no I was
just gonna win the lottery like I think
my kids gonna win somehow I'm gonna do
like five weeks of spa weeks right
before a relaxer and I'm finally calm
Zen oh [ __ ] me
[Music]